[Music]
the new show surviving Jack we have a
cast photo here there you are that's the
family and I see that Chris Maloney who
is on the program
terrific guy I've known him he's been on
the show many times over the years
what's it like playing Chris Melones
wife do you like that I do I mean he's
great to work with I mean and he also
does have the best butt in primetime
yeah I mean you can't I mean honestly
it's it's like you go to work with Chris
and Chris butts and Chris's but he has a
good but you're saying yes have you seen
it have you ever I mean like have you
been well yeah i scope it out all the
time no I think that's the other thing
is guys don't we don't look at each
others butts you know but this is the
thing though if you were really up close
and personal with him like it's turning
around like you like his butt has a
presence that it just makes it presence
I don't really what is it about I mean
I'm just gonna find out now I what is it
about his his well he does a lot of
squats I know he does a lot of squats
but it's just like it's very high
working for something okay he drops a
lot of things I'll get that
SWAT no he's very um he's very into his
body and taking care of himself and and
it really does like it's it's really
it's really a commitment I know you're
weirding all of us out I'm just gonna
say it but I will say I am freaked out
because I never thought that was a part
of a man's body that women cared about
yeah and then you know I started hearing
all the women here talking about
different guests on the show and oh he's
got a good but he's got a good butt and
it enraged me because I have was born
with no but I still have I'm not even
kidding there's it's a straight drop
from my shoulders to the back of my
heels there's nothing there my legs are
held on with strength so I've always
been horrified but that was now suddenly
prized but but you can't deny it
my comment is more about that you can't
deny it now look you are a very tall man
with a great head of hair these two
things you established right away that
you can see my skull through my skin and
then you're acknowledging that I have no
ass and then you're like you do have
hair and it's high in the air because
you're so tight but I'm saying women we
don't really care yes you clearly do
that's all you talk about
I don't care he's like please you're on
your own yeah